Oh welcome to fat man I'll Batman I'm
Kevin Smith
hi I'm Mark Barnard hey welcome to the
scum and villainy Cantina here in
Hollywood on Hollywood Boulevard put
your hands together to the folks at home
know your reel and as a garden gnome
version of me man just put it in your
garden I'm gonna hide behind this
[ __ ] I think it's true I need a stool
so people look hi everybody
not chicken let's get it off there put
it down here I'll sign it we here at the
show for those just listening we always
let folks put stuff up on the bar for us
to sign during the show we got a big-ass
Silent Bob figure that was just too
[ __ ] much mark felt he was being
upstaged he's like I got a deal with
Kevin Smith enough to my right [ __ ] the
one to my left
it's like Kevin the jack Jack's of Kevin
Smith it just keep on popping up around
me all right wait a second before we go
up second further last week we had a
banner [ __ ] show we had Markus and
McFeely the writers of affinity worn all
the Captain America movies the Marvel
Boy and because of that we this show got
a bunch of [ __ ] press all week long I
kept seeing stories pop up and whatnot
it was nice I'll watch the show yeah
well yeah at war one person did and then
every website copied one and wrote about
it and ship a regardless it was kind of
nice to be part of the news cycle in a
positive way you well I mean I I
appreciate the lack of hate for doing a
good thing it was a nice comeback from a
little bar now isn't it like it's the
[ __ ] Internet
appreciate where people don't hate me
but yeah like its I mean I've been that
internet journalist who's like I got a
deuce five stories a day so what are
these five gonna be all right these guys
[ __ ] said something I'm just gonna
write a piece about it then this guy on
indieWIRE I think just wrote a story
saying Markus and McFeely say what they
would do reveal what they would do about
what DC movies should they have the
chance and it like didn't mention the
podcast at all it was just as if I saw
it it mentioned it said Kevin Smith's
fat man I'm Batman but there was no
hyperlink off of it or you know there
was hyperlinks to their names and stuff
like that but they didn't mention you
and they didn't hyperlink the article
which I thought was kind of like [ __ ]
rude and then you know so it was like
4:00 in the morning and I must've
thought it was real rude cuz I tweeted
it
you know it wasn't shitty but it was
kind of shitty at the same time whereas
I came an like we're all digital
journalists to me and Mark Barnard inand
I know I'd hate it if somebody took
their entire article copied it from our
work and like didn't hyperlink back or
even mention the other guy instead so to
be fair they corrected that it was very
Vernon you got to wake up really early
to get one pass Kevin Smith yeah I am
you got no doubt I wake up I'm like
who's [ __ ] me on the Internet
this is the thing I just read before we
came up here man this is a I am going
away this weekend to Seattle to the Ace
Comic Con where apparently like when I
remember Jordan Jason muses wife Jordan
Monsanto she runs our company so she's
the one that says you're going here
you're going here she says you're going
to Seattle to do shows I was just at CEO
and she said this is at a comic book
convention I said oh [ __ ] awesome she
goes plus they want you to moderate
panels and I was like oh man like
Monterey panels for what no like The
Avengers I was like who's dick do I got
a soft tail you should have let with
that you know so I'm getting to do two
panels well and then I just read about
it on
Deadline had an article up that says
Marvel skips San Diego comic-con but
Seattle's is Avengers central this
weekend so number one Marvel's not going
to San Diego this year I'm Marvel movies
is not Marvel TV is Marvel TV viz Marvel
movie Iron Fist is going to the
comic-con so thanks get iron fisted at
Comic Con Kevin Smith it says moderating
number of Avengers panels on Saturday at
11:45 Paul Bettany and Elizabeth Olson
will sit down and field questions about
why nearly everyone disappeared at the
end of infinity war so that's one panel
vision and the Scarlet Witch nice like
they know why but okay yeah-oh is if
they're gonna tell me I'm like ruin your
career spoil something right here in
Seattle but that's gonna be nice I've
met both of them separately and and made
them laugh both separately I met her at
Sundance she was there for four with
with Hawkeye for a movie called win
river I think and when I went to
interview before we interview everybody
I would sit there me like hey man
there's gonna be the easiest [ __ ] of
an interview you'll get all day so relax
and lean back some people didn't enjoy
that analogy but whatever so she went
over to say hey man how are you and she
goes I just wanted to tell you me my
brother used to watch your movies all
the time and stuff and I was like oh
[ __ ] normally I'd tell people it's gonna
be an easy [ __ ] of an interview but
it's gonna be three [ __ ] for you
before you even see anything so sat her
down and talked to her she was lovely
and then Paul Bettany I sat next to on
the couch on talking dead one episode
where one of the episodes was something
intense was happening and it was like
where the Savior's attacked the compound
or something and so I gave an analogy I
was just like watching this episode it
was like how do you do this delicately
on TV I was like it's it's like
receiving oral and then you finish but
the person keeps going and you're like
nah Oh
and [ __ ] Paul Bettany who I'd never
met until that night was sitting next to
me just [ __ ] died laughing and [ __ ]
I could have my way with Paul Bettany
that night so I'm the vision son oh my
god yes I'm a visionary so I'm gonna do
the panel with him and Elizabeth Olsen
that'll be nice and then there's another
one at 6:15 on same-day Smithville habla
with Tom Holland stain of sebastian stan
and anthony mackie for a Captain America
Civil War panel that [ __ ] sounds fun
that should be a blast
however I did get a [ __ ] text from
Jordan going like Tom Hollands agent
wants to know the questions in advance
I'm sure they'll like you can't say you
shoot your web son [ __ ] like that he's
just up Oh Hank totally so I you know I
was like I don't have any questions in
advance the conversations you sit down
whatever you talk about talking about
but I'll promise I won't say anything
[ __ ] untoward I know the dude's got a
big career in [ __ ] like that plus I'm a
fan I'm not gonna sit there and be like
ruin your [ __ ] you're the best
spider-man we ever had now ruin it you
know so yeah man but that big news out
of that wasn't so much hey I'm doing
this but more about Marvel not going to
San Diego that was kind of weird yeah
well I mean it's Andy 23 year or
something like that that's not just a
convention that they do who knows
anybody to 2019 nerd well done we needed
that information so yes there you go man
[ __ ] him who knows why I guess they're
like well they just had what's the next
big movie and the wajal I probably
before Comic Con
I'm sure they'll like we don't want to
go there and have to disappoint [ __ ]
thousands of people when they're like
what happens in Avengers 4 more like
we're not [ __ ] telling you so it
might be easier to stay away yeah and it
costs a fortune to bring Avengers to
[ __ ] comic-con just in travel just in
like you've got to gather people from
all over the world some of which might
be reshooting parts of Avengers 4 yeah
and like put them up first class private
jets all of that [ __ ] [ __ ] totally
and these movies you got to understand
they're into
pennant films they they have no budgets
they have no budget I don't know how
they're gonna fund these adventures but
boy I thought they'd continue but it's
like when you look at the eights
comic-con yeah those guys are getting
paid
are they I'm one of those guys and I
don't know if I'm getting paid and I
hope you are I hope so I just learned
that I'm doing two [ __ ] panel well in
there yeah man it's kind of its kind of
strange though that they're not going to
be at San Diego this year but I guess
they do maybe every other year at this
point they got a thing they'll be there
what is the big thing that's gonna be at
San Diego then is it the Aquaman trailer
I hope there's more than that Wow you
got a high bar I got an incredibly low
bar I'm like just show me a little
Aquaman in my face I'll be fine like I
don't need a whole [ __ ] yeah well I will
tell you one thing that will be a
comic-con Castlerock will be at Kanto oh
[ __ ] the JJ Abrams show based on the
work of Stephen King written by fat man
on Batman co-host Mark Barnard in that
show written by me and like nine other
people but uh we we are showing the
pilot episode at Comic Con oh [ __ ] we're
Ballroom 2018 nice it's yeah it's like
mm maybe 2025 people in there yes it'll
show sometime that week before the
premiere on the 25th are you going to be
on a panel of some sort there if so that
would mean they are desperate for
panelists because I will you be in the
audience of that I will be front [ __ ]
row I don't think I will be on the dais
unless I get the call like the [ __ ]
castle rock signal goes in the air like
we need you get in the car I don't know
man not for nothing I understand like
they got JJ Abrams and a cast of people
and stuff but you do carry a [ __ ]
audience that there would be like 30
people in that crowd just waiting here
where's bernard in'
well that sounds [ __ ] exciting what
what have you been doing this week I
know you were busy
that's we did something very cryptic I'm
all about the cryptic because I got a
job I told you this I am on a new
television show yes which I started the
part of the show where I have to pretend
I don't know what's really going on to
mark but yes I joined the writing staff
of a television show called Treadstone
[ __ ] time so anybody listening to the
show should know that this is a guy
worth [ __ ] hiring smartest dude in
the room alright so Treadstone sounds
like comes from the world of Jason
Bourne no it does come from the world of
Jason Bourne and that is all I can say
about the show that comes from the world
of Jason Bourne for two reasons hey I
can't [ __ ] say anything because
they'll kill me on sight and with like a
magazine or a phone book or a hairdryer
a rolled-up magazine yeah it's neck
punch and B I started working two days
ago like we don't know what the [ __ ]
show is yet so that is that's the
process right now when what we call the
blue sky process where it's you kind of
just like sit back in your chair like
you're looking at the blue sky and say
well what if we did this what if this
happened what if we went there let me
ask you this as a as a veteran of
writers rooms when you're in a blue sky
period when you guys enter the room does
and is there any are there any bones
whatsoever is it literally like we're
building the [ __ ] whole cloth right from
everybody in this room like somebody had
to get a job off this [ __ ] in order to
be a charge of the writers room and I
must have had an idea right there is
there's a pilot script that we're
working off of but it's it's you know a
pilot is is the first rung of tracks in
a very long [ __ ] path right and the
pilot also hasn't been shot yet so it's
hey we could change whatever we wanted
to in a pilot we can we can go back and
alter whatever we think would make the
most sense going forward but what's the
rest of the show gonna be where these
characters gonna go who's gonna get
punched in the neck who's gonna
nope to the wake part of the process
tool again [ __ ] a blue sky part 1 part 2
neck punching that's my process anyway
listen we got a punch like somebody in
the neck every eight minutes how many
people in the room writers room seven
seventeen not including the showrunner
seven to write ten episodes yeah so
eight people to write ten episodes yeah
pretty much
what is what's the I know you can't talk
about details but what is the how does
it feel between this and the other gig
when you walked into the Castle Rock
riders room I mean they're both somewhat
burdened by legacy I think you know like
the Stephen King of oh [ __ ] like the
most popular American author in the
history of books is Stephen King and so
now you've got a conjure up a show that
feels worthy of being the Stephen King
quote-unquote production right and this
also is like people have lived with
Jason Bourne they've lived with both
from the novel's first is it a Muslim
and so it's it's it's figuring out how
to subvert expectations while still
delivering the kind of thing people want
and I think that's gonna be a big part
of the early process is what what do
people expect to get out of something
like this where and how can we give them
what they don't expect but didn't know
they needed it smells like you're trying
to figure out how to make a Jason Bourne
story without Jason Bourne I feel for
you that's exciting man that means you
get to go anywhere with it we totally do
I mean it's it's nothing but freedom
aside from what feels right and that's a
good way to go
you're an absolutely a great person to
have in the room for that sort of thing
how long you in that process or is the
Canadians a process in this the blue sky
process could be anywhere from two to
five weeks maybe
when are you higher abow again I well
and that your own thing could kick in
the only could kick in I mean Castle
Rock may or may not get a season two and
I may or may not return back for it so I
go back on the on the market whatever
the writers version of tender is
somebody should make that up because
we're all stuff loathing people who need
love so when I go back on the market in
November December and then we see what
happens going forward but I've actually
employed through Christmas at the very
least that's [ __ ] also it's a good
yeah babies get presents Marc's got a
job till Christmas give it up for him
ladies I this is [ __ ] stunning ooh
who's got a story on this man what's the
story documentary on ballet Brian who
played miss Tessmacher yeah look at that
has an awesome G neck he's he's amazing
my buddy it's it's he's quite incredible
beautiful man I get to keep this yeah
that's yours oh my god what do I have to
do for it we could talk I'd like to do
an interview with at some point for my
documentary a little short happily hook
it up through him he'll help you out
painting mr. Luthor yeah okay oh I went
to the movies what did you see I went to
go see Jurassic world fallen Kingdom the
oh [ __ ] man and did it fall was it
Kingdom what's up how did you feel about
the first Jurassic world movie the one
that Colin Trevorrow did yes I enjoyed
the [ __ ] out of it I thought it was a
real like throwback and whatnot made me
go [ __ ] I remember how much I like
Jurassic Park in 1993 or whatever
so I I it worked on me remember that
time when this was good
I'm bitter it erased like the memories
of Jurassic Park 3 and stuff and took me
right back to the first one and I I
thought they did a good job yeah this
one's better than that first one is that
right it is yeah
let's how did you feel about the first
one I guess that's what matters I was I
was a little tepid on it it's one of
those things where like in the moment
like oh this is kind of fun if it's
running and jumping whatever but the
minute you walk out of there start
thinking about it like oh well what do
you mean what I'm thinking about you
like dinosaurs aren't real this is
[ __ ]
my money back you've lied to me but this
this is it this is a better movie than
the first one is but it's still kind of
falters in me like this this feels like
a remake of the lost world Jurassic Park
ok which isn't bad but you can tell
there's two halves of that movie it's
we're going to this island to get
dinosaurs off of the island for some
reason not going to say why yet and then
we're going back to the mainland with
these dinosaurs and shit's gonna go
wrong that is pretty much happen in the
second Jurassic Park that's the second
drastic park and it's mmm when I saw the
trailer they're a bunch of you going oh
[ __ ] the dinosaurs have come the land
I'm like that did that yes we seen this
yeah we had our oh [ __ ] moment and
Spielberg did it it was one of his he
directed that one correct and so this
one is a J a Bayona who did Matsumoto
monster calls the monster calls and
there's another movie today that I can't
remember the disaster movie with Naomi
Watts right right where she's at the
resort with her husband and the family
and then a [ __ ] flood hits it's
harrowing movies is that what it's got
the impossible [ __ ] beautiful flick
and also you just like holy [ __ ] look
like hell defy the spider-man's in that
movie Tom ah [ __ ] there's something I
could [ __ ] say okay I was doing a
podcast and you came up I have one
Austin here's the question I'm gonna ask
him tell me about the impossible totally
yeah
this movie is really inventive like the
thriller stuff is really great there's
some nice horror beats to it there's an
interesting character stuff but when it
all coalescence into a whole you like
that was your big idea that's what this
is I mean okay alright what uh Wow to
spoil it because I mean you'll get there
totally you'll all get there doesn't
make all the money uh yeah I mean it's
it's it's already made like 300 million
overseas its projected to open it like
130 140 150 domestic so the dinosaurs
are going extinct no time soon oh
there's gonna be more of these for a
long time was there an ending that left
it open for yeah it also feels a little
bit like whatever dawn of the Planet of
the Apes was the first one or rise of
the point of the Apes of the first one
are we gonna go to [ __ ] war with the
dinosaurs [ __ ] never dinosaurs on
horseback with machine or small
dinosaurs riding bigger dinosaurs
Colombian man they've really got my
interest back in this franchise yeah so
so there's there's some things too
there's some things to advocate for this
movie but then there's also they like
what's your idea that's your idea okay I
guess you could have tried again but
didn't we're making a movie so yes I saw
that one which you know again it's it
tickles the pleasures that you want to
be tickled is it Pratt tastic there's a
couple of moments in that movie where
it's like you can tell that somebody
wants him to be Harrison Ford real real
[ __ ] bad like I think there's a
sequence of to you in the trailer when
he's running down the same [ __ ]
plains of Hawaii running away from
dinosaurs as Indiana Jones running away
from natives in the beginning of Raiders
of Lost Time
really the same [ __ ] run the same
[ __ ] angle the same [ __ ] place in
Hawaii what you trying to do yeah
excited a producer Steven Spielberg he's
a charm factory man I'll watch him do
anything including my wife how they
could go for it only if she likes to
fish why is the inefficient he's a huge
[ __ ] fisherman all right yeah how do
you [ __ ] know this Instagram
that's what he puts into his speed like
I caught a biggie fish it's like Harry
on my press junket or look at the size
of this [ __ ] fish haha what a great
life man he's like I'd do two things
I sell movies and I kill fish every one
of these fish was in my way
did he is he catch and release guy Rosie
yeah I don't know I haven't gotten that
deep in News Instagram stories tube-like
now he's worth don't [ __ ] pull back
now I realize I supposed to know my well
because he gets like crazy deep
Republican in there so I kind of like
pull back after a while is he a crazy
jib what yeah really yeah okay
just saying so like I'll watch them fish
and watch them like mug nice but then
once you get deep into like Nugent
territorial Iowa no I don't want them to
go there so I don't even follow that
deep in case that's where the road ends
interesting is this a bad [ __ ] dead
end
alright so thumbs up or thumbs down you
know gently erect getting it come in
need of Viagra you are you're getting
tough in your old age man you know a
little bit but you know I liked I really
like The Incredibles too though
yes I still haven't seen that this week
this week I want to see hereditary which
I wanted to like more than I did but I
enjoyed I went in going like oh [ __ ] I
think I know what it's gonna be and I
came out going what the [ __ ]
and I'm in no position to criticize I
[ __ ] made this movie so you know I'm
sure the filmmaker would be like boy I
saw tusks shut up but uh it was there
was a lot of elements at play that were
like right up my alley so yeah is is
different I I will not go see that
because I'm a [ __ ] you don't do the I
haven't done a harvest for a long time
my last horror movie I saw in a feeder
was Dawn of the Dead the remake watch it
was like [ __ ] for bad DC movies ago
man like that's why I kept having hope
dumb [ __ ] man a great movie that
is a great movie man that daughter
Deborah make especially with the bard
had to clear I loved the first movie and
they found a way to make one that stands
by itself honors the original and is its
own flick written by James Gunn oh
that's right oh my god that's [ __ ] up
I forgot about that all right man is
that it all those all the [ __ ]
chopping up I got got up front I turned
in an outline yesterday for this thing
that I've been working on which they
haven't announced yet so I'm not for you
to talk about it but hoping that when if
they pull the trigger on this thing you
know [ __ ] I'll be able to be like come
play but will you go play I know but you
might be all up in Treadstone or you
might be on your own thing I will life
finds awake in it it's profound
where'd you get that from the one scene
that Ian Malcolm is a fixer Ezek world
where that like all he says the whole
[ __ ] time so he's in only one scene
yeah I mean it's the scene you've seen
in the commercials where he's like its
own testimony in front of Congress or it
explains all of the bad [ __ ] they've
been doing it for four movies so you
don't go back to the island he read the
script he's like this dress park - I was
in this goodbye listen the Goldblum does
not run or jump anymore I will sit here
and like just awkwardly syntax some [ __ ]
for you but I'm not gonna run away from
anything true I just want a faster not
much run faster he's having a moment
isn't he that [ __ ] guy didn't he
release like an album or something I saw
well he does he plays and I've never
seen him but sit that where is it the
Dresden is that it where he plays jazz
like every Thursday somewhere here in LA
yeah let's be nice to be Goldblum
chill-out I play jazz people okay you
were the fly and he's like alright let's
dive in [ __ ] a man mark barnard went
all over the internet to find all the
news that's [ __ ] fit to print in the
section of the show we call the news
give it up for mark but not in a way
Avenue give us some [ __ ] good news
because today all the [ __ ] news in
the real world is [ __ ] bleak I tell
you I was so delighted to come to this
show took a nap at one point today I
woke up look at the real news and I was
like [ __ ] I'm retreating to Fantasyland
so I like coming here and talking about
like like this [ __ ] as if it matters
like this is the real this is gonna make
or break the world what do we go I mean
this this I like to look at it as we're
playing the best [ __ ] song while the
Titanic goes down okay so you cannot
very [ __ ] hold full boat okay now
we're gonna [ __ ] rock it out it's
immigrant song yeah it's good metaphor
see what I did there yes Incredibles -
opened and broke all kinds of [ __ ]
records did it 182 million dollar
opening weekend which is the highest for
any animated movie in history Wow Wow
yeah that's [ __ ] big that's pretty
[ __ ] huge good for them what's his
name Brad Bird telling you talent that
kid storyteller that kid Brad Bird he's
gonna go places he's got a future I
still haven't seen it we were gonna go
on father's day but we wound up
redditor inst a big [ __ ] mistake I
mean but the title is like we should go
Father's Day write a Jerry there must be
a theme and then we walked out my wife
was just like never again you know what
I'd know her Father's Day
well I went to the Glendale Galleria
this company called voice VR has a star
war secrets of Omaha
there is the Star Wars VR experience
awesome it was cool
[ __ ] badass I've spoken to people I
did it you put on your stormtrooper you
put it yeah you put on it you're your
task on this mission where you're
pretending to be a stormtrooper so you
put on the VR goggles in this backpack
that you carry with you in the backpack
gives you all of the sensation of being
shot and when things are hot you get hot
what do they call a net something tick
haptic haptic tactics yes yeah but it's
[ __ ] awesome it's like 8 9 10 minutes
long but you're walking through an
imperial base you're shooting
stormtroopers in the face you may or may
not come across a Dark Lord of the Sith
all of this [ __ ] is kind of amazing
really and how big of a space you get to
walk around it's unclear because you
don't know but you're walking absolutely
and it's moving but you don't know like
you're scanning on a skiff and the skiff
is taking you over lava fields and
you're like this is cool I haven't moved
I feel like I'm moving though you walk
you make it right and I'm like you go
through another door you come back and
you might be the same place you were
before it's the most [ __ ] fun you can
have with like a little tear for a
minute man my wife is not happy because
I relived it the entire rest of the day
boo-boo how many on a scale of four pues
how many peopie's it is three-and-a-half
Q's only because it's not longer oh
you'd like to be a little bit longer but
like I want to live there I could spend
the weekend how much did it cost to do
ah 30 bucks
okay worth every penny yeah can you do
it with others are you solo you do it
most a party of three I dated with my
son is there I can see him like I'm in
there and I look over he's got a
stormtrooper eyes waving at me and [ __ ]
it's a stormtrooper thing like dad I got
shot in the face
shoot back in the face okay gotta be
honest with you it sounds more
interesting than solo well done
[Applause]
wow man [ __ ] it was there a long line or
no it was crazy cuz it's Father's Day so
like you don't go on Father's Day
you don't let some down between now and
then you should go but don't go on
Father's Day
what was the wait time though uh we
would four o'clock reservations we got
to go if you can make reservation by
your tickets and they give you like kids
you give you a wait time and we have to
wait 45 minutes before we actually got
on the [ __ ] ride but you could walk
on the mall and go do some [ __ ] or a
food court Glendale go yeah outdoor mall
no the Americana is the outdoor mall the
Glendale no gallery is still there that
that was the Americana now oh my god
during the Glendale Galleria oh I'd like
to shame they took it down they're like
we're right here and we're dying alright
so that's a reason to get into the
Glendale I would I would go if I were
you they got one at Disneyland I think
at Disney downtown or something like
this same one I think a little more
intense at Disney or something yes you
have you been to both and the one it is
downtown Disney's same thing same thing
fuckin'-a alright so far climb down yeah
you go to the gallery and they got one
in New York they do ghostbusters in New
York where else you you go into other
movies because I don't want to be here
at all
in our world I just want to keep diving
into movies shooting little
stormtroopers in the face when do you
get the Oasis cuz I'm gonna move in I
know
[ __ ] this Wow there's a ghost posters
Rome New York and is there an aliens one
I heard or an alien
if you get two people you do a what what
is that and what was your word for it
dual wield a wielding as in like
wielding a gun yeah and then thank you
for the cuz you double the pew man 30
bucks 30 bucks my man [ __ ] it let's go
now I got a jack [ __ ] yeah we got some
[ __ ] to do right now alright back to the
news actually so that was the
Incredibles did very well
elbows beyond as expected we all thought
it would do well but bucket did a lot
yeah yeah so go see it add your 10 bucks
to the to the till they'll get mine for
sure I love that movie I just haven't
had a chance I was working on something
else for the same company you was busy I
was a practice were you an a fan of
invincible Robert Kirkman superhero book
but based on the expression on my face
know that you know not that not that I
wasn't a fan I'm like what is it down
what so he did this video opposed his
yeah that you know about a kid who
discovers that his dad was an
intergalactic superhero and then maybe
not so much but he like it's it's a
coming-of-age severe it was spider-man
basically he wanted to do with
spider-man in the same way they like
Macduff he wanted to do spider-man with
static shock he wanted to do spider-man
so he gave this invincible and it was
his second longest-running book he went
in for 15 years I could there's a movie
that paramount is making with Seth Rogen
and Evan Goldberg writing it but they
also just set up a animated series on
Amazon I'll have invincible like and for
like real adult blood and violence and
viscera and Oliver G all like yeah yeah
yeah so and this is part of the first
thing under Kirkman is overall deal in
Amazon because he left
AMC at Amazon yeah so this is the first
of his I'm bringing you guys all of the
good [ __ ]
where's your enthusiasm level for it oh
you a big invincible guy I read the
first like four trades and I really
liked it and there's totally a world in
which that makes all the
in the world it's an hour-long show
which is interesting hour-long animated
they don't do very much Wow but yeah I
mean I'll [ __ ] watch it like if it's
if it's smart and if it's good you know
like I got prime not gonna cost me a
damn thing except for that hundred and
forty dollars a hit you a year for prime
but wait a second Seth Rogen's doing a
movie at the same time yeah a
live-action movie for Paramount yeah so
and nobody seems to be blinking so I
think they're just gonna make both
alright look out for my god familiarize
myself with this yes you do there was a
there was a kind of an amazing interview
on Entertainment Weekly
we're giving credit where credit is due
with Toby Emmerich the head of Warner
Brothers films okay and he's talking
about how to make good DC movies did he
watch our show last week is that how he
knows no because here was his answer I
think good movies work better he's on to
something somebody once said the best
business strategy motion pictures is
quality and I think in a world of rotten
tomatoes and social media what's been
proven the better the movie particularly
the superhero genre the better performs
you can't hide the bacon anymore
well glad he's in charge I mean to be
fair that should have been job one yeah
it's not true of everything do you
really have to make four movies to be
like you know we figured out this would
work better people like these movies go
figure its scientific yeah continuing I
would say the there are movies that are
the right for their time that an
audience is ready for that then sync
with the zeitgeist and I think you need
a movie whose quality is recognized at
the moment of release so it is in touch
with the culture of the moment we're at
a unique moment he's fond of the word
moment when you unique moment on the
planet and certain types of movies are
working better than others at this
moment of time and I do you think
Aquaman will sync up with the global
culture zeitgeist of what's happening
right now
can I make a statement you have the
floor sir I think in order to breathe we
need oxygen put that in Entertainment
Weekly yeah I have spoken [ __ ] man like
well god bless he's a nice guy I've met
him once or twice out in the world and
stuff he seems like a nice dude but like
yeah that's kind of been obvious to the
rest of us well it's nice to hear
somebody inside be like yeah we [ __ ]
up you guys in so many what if we made
these good yeah
novel idea sir how they've got Aquaman
happening next and then they just talked
about Joker
today they released or Joker [ __ ] yeah
the working title of it is god dammit
what was it
Joker's wild it's not hard Joker I hold
I hardly know her no hope that's not bad
[ __ ] I forget what a Romeo that's its
codename my working title is called
Romeo but something I read and this is
the one that's directed by Todd Phillips
and Joaquin Phoenix is playing the Joker
they said it's going to hone close to
the Killing Joke so it's gonna tell that
story which means maybe Batman's in it
as well I mean how do you have a joker
movie without Batman right they can
barely make a Batman movie without the
Joker most days what should we do
poison the water supply I don't know I
don't look if they're making Killing
Joke we're gonna Maul for it
like that'd be tremendous but this is
not one of those DC extended universe
movies this is a black easy dark there
were over there calling it yeah alright
well I'm still holding that hope man I
saw some pictures from Aquaman and
Entertainment Weekly they looked
interesting that mirror hairdo is pretty
orange but Amen man they had armed ocean
masters in it so I'm [ __ ] I'm there
and they showed a picture of Black Manta
yeah with his helmet and the helmet was
ridiculously big and they could have
gotten away with like we're not doing
that but it looks like they're giving
them the [ __ ] helmet and if they do
that they
all my money I mean there let's be
honest they're getting my money
regardless but if they do it with black
man's I could go out there and good
conscience and be you should all give
your money as well bethenny yes but if I
go to that movie and that was just a
scene where he's looking at the helmet
he goes nah and then wears something
else fuck'em you know there's no pay the
oceans will rise but what if that
something else is like a can go then he
just [ __ ] turns on backwards that
would that bug me a little bit yeah when
the helmet was right there
so I'm in for that they put up pictures
this week of gal gadot we're in the
Wonder Woman alpha woman 84 they Steve
Trevor rolling around which I did were
you the one that said they could do that
I wouldn't have enough they're telling
people that you said yeah Martian men
are that they could be Martian manner
that would be a way to bring a Martian
Manhunter into the DC Universe that
would be [ __ ] fantastic what are the
chances of that being I mean you know
like given that Geoff Johns has a decent
oh he's co-writing of the movie Geoff
Johns the like he was a dude who made
sure that Martian Manhunter was in
Supergirl like he's right or die for
that character like it would not be the
craziest idea in the world that'd be
[ __ ] tremendous that'd be might be a
great way to introduce that character to
the DC Universe I remember there's a
podcast where it was one of the writers
what's his name Allen Feinberg know from
DC who wrote like Man of Steel you know
he writes all the DC superhero movies oh
you know going here
Boyer Gore is on a podcast where they
talked about I heart out you could never
you could you couldn't really do Martian
Manhunter cuz it's a goofy character and
I completely like disagree if you do a
you know Superman Clark Kent
[ __ ] kal-el from Krypton you can
absolutely do the Martian manner so I
hope it's that if you can do [ __ ]
Groot then you can do Martian Manhunter
you know
Kidwell Marvel could do anything that
we've learned cinematically DC is still
figuring it out alright what else we got
were you did you still watching Walking
Dead is anybody here still watching yeah
I watched most of last season I don't I
don't think I was tough when they killed
off Carl I was like honestly man like
spoilers hey man like pop culture moves
ever forward like you gotta stay on top
of these things but yeah that that was
kind of not wasn't like [ __ ] him to
death but that was where I was like well
I feel no need to keep up on this I'll
watch it all when it's all concluded and
stuff not as much as like the the two
you know flash and Supergirl I watched
like every when they drop and stuff like
that they just finished up last night I
think it was Supergirl finished their
season it was great you know who's
coming back to the Walking Dead for the
ninth season yes you can't protect Rick
[ __ ] Shane man explain this [ __ ]
I didn't [ __ ] I mean spoilers didn't
get Reggie's and once spoilers shoot him
in the [ __ ] face yeah so is he coming
back as like brain I think so because he
then goes back to the grave and then
cuts the head offered like him pokes a
stake through or whatever because he
doesn't want Shane to come back that
happens in the first season he did that
yeah so then how they [ __ ] doing this
flashback is my acid in The Walking Dead
he went into the ground and spiked the
body Jim really really I don't remember
it was a long time ago I guess but my
guess is it's a flashback because he's
only back for one episode and I think
it's part of anjou Lincoln's [ __ ]
[ __ ] non-story is this the like
shades back
[ __ ] for a memory for one episode
that's not gonna stab the wounds of
losing Andrew Lincoln Andrew Lincoln
announced that he's done yeah soon right
yeah like halfway through season nine I
think he's gonna bid farewell and then
what's-his-face Norman Reedus is number
one of the call sheet he's negotiating
some twenty million dollar deal to be
the lead of that show to keep going yeah
Wow cuz yeah I get paid Darryl as the
lead yeah all right you always function
kind of better as you know the Han Solo
off to the side type but he's front and
center I like Norman Rita's good actor
I guess season 10 will be solo but with
zombies yes
season season 10 is gonna be all of them
going to a place and fighting things
that aren't zombies and talking a lot
negan's still on that show right I think
so yeah take your word for it call me
when that's done I like him a lot he's
great actor with that character hurt
that storyline so much just went on and
on and on and stuff so uh yeah that
might get me to I'll definitely be
watching the Shane episode because I
want to see how they pull it off my
guess is Wayne in garthen what else we
go uh I've been waiting to do this pun
for a long time it is one of my
favorites Netflix made a deal with the
devil to bring Lucifer back from
cancellation that's right I did see that
story Lucifer which was on Fox Fox they
were gone through the throes of
cancellation they were about two or
three weeks the save Lucifer campaign
was strong that's right
and I think ultimately what held it up
was the fact that Lucifer is owned by
Warner Brothers was on Fox the streaming
rights were with Hulu and overseas they
were streaming with somebody else and
then Netflix is like we're gonna pick up
this show we need all of it like what's
the [ __ ] point if we can't stream
seasons 1 through whatever we're gonna
produce it is right so it took them
three weeks to
to dot all the i's and cross all the t's
but yeah season four is coming in
netflix have you been a lucifer guy I am
a Lucifer diehard oh really
yeah so when they cancelled it really
there's a little bit I mean every season
it's one of those shows that never knew
when it was coming back if it was coming
back right it would find a way to like
put a nice button on the season like if
we don't never come back again
look what happened which is exactly what
they did and there's a little bit of oh
[ __ ] you could have gone a whole nother
season there's enough juice there's
enough in this tank to get you there
how's the guy plays Lucifer he is
delicious
I mean he's plummy and Brittish she's
like you know what if what if Paul
Bettany had a darker younger brother
what did they do now this is a game ins
loose right is there other game and
universe stuff in there no it's just
Lucifer walks the earth gets into jams
his mazikeen in it mazikeen is in it
Cain played a really big role oh [ __ ] in
this season so it is very and he
actually was the voice of God Neil
Gaiman I got Gaiman to play the voice of
God in the very last episode get the
[ __ ] out of here oh my god yeah you just
sold a ticket
hey typecasting and as far as I'm
concerned what getting you with the god
yeah so that's happening and the very
last story okay is yeah were you you're
a shining guy right yeah oh my god who's
not absolutely both I was a big fan of
the Stephen King book and separately a
big fan of Kubrick's movie you know and
the two are share a lot of similarities
but they also diverge in big ways and
King famously did not enjoy the movie
but I enjoy both renditions of The
Shining the only shining I wasn't way
onboard with was the one with yeah the
TV movie I just thought it was crazy was
that what's-his-name from wings yeah
Steven Weber Steven Weber who's a really
[ __ ] funny actor and [ __ ] but like
that's that's a big role to take on and
stuff and
you know I didn't think that was really
necessary but I like the I like it a lot
they're doing a sequel yes Stephen King
wrote a book called dr. sleep follows
grown-up Danny Torrance and one of
others is making a movie which will
start Ewan McGregor as grown-up Danny
Torrance I think it's great casting who
is the director he's done something else
I must have cut that out there's these
things don't just direct themselves Marc
there's a guy I forget his name later
something earlier I think you did it the
guy who did it oh is that right yeah
yeah speculation with Kevin mark filling
in the blank so awkwardly couple
together new stories do you look forward
to this I do I do I mean I remember
seeing where we saw it [ __ ] ready
player one and they have that sequence
that's spoiler alert in the Overlook
Hotel and it just reminded me how much I
loved that movie
and to get to play with that character
again the [ __ ] the boy who saw evil
and the boy who could talk to the dead
and the boy if you do all that [ __ ]
grown up like what's that guy like today
mm-hmm
when that's your gift you can see murder
coming do you think if Danny's coming
back to Stony come back the little boy
that lives in his mouth god I hope so
that'd be creepy to watch him in front
of a mirror in that music yeah it's just
like Danny I'm an adult now scratch I
barking off
Wow Manny I can't wait I'm in line for
that movie in a big bad way that's what
do you get honors it's got it right like
yeah you know he's gonna lean into the
Kubrick of it all and you know it's
going to end at the Overlook Hotel you
think so yeah I want to live in your
world man writes his beautiful details I
hope you're [ __ ] right about that oh
wow that makes it even more cool all
right so are they gonna call it doctor
dr. sleep yeah or or shining - electric
murders shining - shining time station
all right that's all the news there is
and there's one more bit they forgot to
write down but last week I believe it
will s you Comcast made a bid for Fox an
all-cash bid of like 65 billion dollars
yeah which is 12 billion more than
Disney's bid no I don't know it was a
higher bid it was a higher bid and it's
all cash it's not stock it's like we're
backing up a [ __ ] truck and here's
all your money now comcast has some loop
but I gotta imagine Disney has way more
loot than that take Disney backs down
there's no way they come that close to
hold them the x-men in their hands again
and going yeah give it to the cable
company I don't know but I mean NBC
Universal which owns Comcast like they
got loot they're good with franchise
management they got parks like there's a
world in which like if there was anybody
to have a good competing bid that would
be that would be it so meanwhile across
the street Warner Brothers just got
bought didn't they AT&T or merged and
there's going to be three companies at
the end of the world basically that
owned everything and do all of the
things and there's no more competition
it's just hyper big a global net do you
think in our lifetime we get to see
Warner Brothers and Disney combined so
that [ __ ] Marvel and DC can finally
fight each other on the big scale
you know yes show you it's coming as
Walmart we'll buy them both all right
that's all the news we got as all the
news money from last week we had
fabulous [ __ ] guests we have no
guests this way we have we have we just
have our the guests who showed up our on
our wonderful guests here in Rome the
good news is last week you got to ask
goddamn industry professionals questions
man and they yielded great answers and
stuff this week you're stuck asking me
and Marc will try to do as best we can
this is the Q&A portion part of the show
ladies and gentlemen and in this section
we turn to the audience and let five
people ask questions and all we ask is
that the questions pertain to both me
and Marc is you know don't lean into a
cab centric question or a Marc centric
question so I will talk about Moose Jaw
is all [ __ ] Dan yes as much as he
likes talking about moose just we'd like
to cover it allows us to cover a lot
more a variety of topics so what you do
is you ask a question we'd like your
question you're gonna win two tickets to
the 4dx theater which is an LA live a 40
x screening is one of those movies where
you sit in the chair and the chair moves
and it blows [ __ ] into your face and
makes the room smell and if it's snowing
on screen it snows in the room it's
pretty fabulous experience pricey right
little premium it cost a little bit more
than going to the movie so these two
tickets here are pretty [ __ ] valuable
man it's a wonderful experience go watch
like a big-budget movie in 40x trust me
you'll never see one of my movies in 40x
because nobody wants to watch people
talk to each other in 4dx they want [ __ ]
to happen but great experience great
time in the movies tickets courtesy of
our good friend of the show
Brett Deacon who's not here tonight he
didn't die it's not like God rest his
soul he just can't be here tonight he's
working and stuff Peter killed it oh my
god that 40x experience was so real it
killed Britney so we're gonna turn it
over to JC proprietor of this year scum
and villainy cantina in Hollywood to
pick our question-asker and our first
question asked her is there what's your
name good sir hey it's Sam
I'll give it up for Sam Sam in that very
spot last week Markus and McFeely stood
man can you feel their billion-dollar
energy surrounding that spot I think I
feel it yeah what do you want to know
man tell us so first off thank you guys
for everything I ingest hours of your
content every week you it's awesome so
thank you for all of that and putting up
for free mostly thanks man what I was
thinking is with the announcement that
Jon Favreau's Star Wars live-action
series will be set seven years after
Jedi and then they're still not deciding
what the game of thrones guys and what
the Rian Johnson gonna be if gave you
those properties what part of the former
Star Wars can in which you reach on to
in order to I would go populist I would
go Knights of the Old Republic like
that's the one part of the legacy or the
saga or the Star Wars mythos that really
hasn't been like picked over a thousand
times yeah that's where I go you I think
I mean we talked about a little bit when
rogue one came out I think I loved the
idea of doing a thing about the the fall
of Jeddah of the the Khyber mines and
the [ __ ] acolytes who were defending
the the home of the Jedi but weren't
Jedi and what it's like to be force
aligned but not actually wielding the
force and then those ever [ __ ]
lightsaber but the the Alamo of Star
Wars feels like that's that story and I
think there's a lot of [ __ ] drama in
there so that's that's where I'd go
about you you're a fan kind of lined up
with mark the Guardians the wills just
grabbed me I enjoyed the book that they
wrote but I'm those two actors just
stole that movie format really like to
see him dig into those characters did
you see last week there was a story
about I don't know if it's been verified
but somebody says this is what George
Lucas I guess it was George Lucas
himself was in an interview and he says
this is what I was going to do if it
were me and it was about he was doubling
down on midi-chlorians
yeah it was crazy in a world where
everybody was like who the Jedi blood
thing don't do that George he's like
[ __ ] you twice yeah there's your [ __ ]
Star Wars you know so I guess we know
now why Kathy Kennedy was like the Hanks
but goodbye and everything special about
you came out of a bottle I mean it could
have been ah who knows he might have
made it something interesting but it
sounds like it sounded pretty crazy
sounded a little on the weird side it's
an entire movie said at the microbiotic
level I believe was the quote and that's
that that's what it read like to me
where I was like wait so are these that
Mike robotics that look like have the
head of Luke Skywalker on them or
something or are we losing them
altogether crowlike weight or shrink
[ __ ] down I've got to go into
Obi Wan's body and like fine [ __ ] see
that could work all I could picture was
the film I watched in elementary school
about the smallpox vaccine gone through
the bloodstream okay seems like Lucas
watched the same movie and was like
that's my next trilogy
alright man's great question give it up
for me Winston GATS you're leavin town
oh [ __ ] man Sam's leaving Jones I ain't
taking the tickets alright so we can do
no you can absolutely get a picture I
think that George Lucas still wants to
answer questions nobody was asking how
are you sir what's your name you got
microphone Mike Mike give it up for Mike
ever since they announced excellent
excellent shirt man little Tom Petty
love right there ever since they
announced Jamie Foxx doing spawn I've
been wondering if there's a spawn there
has to be a violator so who you guys
would like to see cast as violator or
what others starting as the clown going
to the violator interesting question
last time it was John Leguizamo wearing
a [ __ ] ton of makeup who do I go with
this time mmm tough one it was
unrealistic but you know but he did come
out of retirement to act fairly recently
Nicholson man like he played a famous
clown once before and [ __ ] crushed it
so I might reach that far back you I
think I go either Vincent D'Onofrio a
better choice or Benicio del Toro oh
yeah what the [ __ ] is just weird enough
that you don't even need the makeup was
that the question
you [ __ ] one get those tickets bad
boy we got another one man what's your
name my name is Jamie I won't give it up
for Jamie Jamie what can we do you for
well I'm travelling on business and just
ran across this so thanks for having
this case oh how does the bar hold up to
like when you first read about dawn this
could be interesting this is dope give
it up for JC's bar what's your question
so it more industry type stuff so you're
talking about Stephen King which is like
my jam so when you guys are sitting in a
writers room and you've got ten writers
like is it like the [ __ ] Hunger Games
like how do you decide who gets what
episode and where's that can I come in
that's a great question I've never been
in the writers room I too would like to
know well in in a writers room in a
drama writers room and it's not the
Hunger Games
in a comedy writers room those
[ __ ] are like knife and tooth
tooth and now they are merciless people
but but the way it ends up working is
you spend months in a room just doing
this story doing the big work of here's
the ten episodes we're gonna tell here's
the 22 episodes but here's our giant
story and then you start siloing those
stories in two episodes and then
somebody usually the showrunner will say
you do that way you do that when you do
that when you do that one now in that
process of spending the five six seven
eight nine weeks in the room breaking
those stories your show burner will
begin - no -
like somebody's gravitating more to that
one because that's their speed
storytelling this one is a deep
character piece this one has a bunch of
car chases this one is about magic and
that guy's I remember the Magic Castle
so let him do that one whatever it is
like there's not what it comes down to
and I've been married it's like he said
magic once give him that I mean the way
it's it it should work is that you know
you've got a team full of people and
everybody gets an episode and if you're
doing 22 episodes everybody will get two
and three because that's just the way it
works but you know sometimes it's
rotation sometimes it's you just up this
is yours go to work and then you usually
get between two and three weeks to break
off from the room totally and go right
and you come back with a draft and then
it belongs to the room then everybody
reads it everybody gives notes on it the
showrunner will rewrite it to make it
fit the voice of the show and then let's
do it again yeah what can a man that's
informative a [ __ ] I even I learned
something well you're welcome
give it up her you won tickets man thank
you
all right JC give us somebody else how
are you sir what's your name my name is
Steven Steven everyone give it up for a
longtime listener and they really enjoy
the podcast been listening since that
the first Dinny interview listening
since the Batman commentaries mark I
love you the permanent edition and I
thank you Mark for your perspectives all
right classic but I truly want to blow
smoke up JC's ass cuz I really love scum
and villainy I have been here many times
this truly feels like the geek Cheers
where everyone knows your name except
mine everyone knows your name but mine
cuz I have a 16 month old and if I've
learned anything from Hansel and
midi-chlorians is don't mean absentee
father right
in honor of our geek cheers though I
really wanted to ask a fun
what's the geek bar room argument to ask
and to myspace Norman Cheers actually
want to ask two questions this first one
though it's because it's a ranking
question I'm okay with a lot meet social
media posts but a Star Wars versus Star
Trek question there have been 10 Star
Wars movies there have been 13 Star Trek
movies they've been ranked varies ranked
them together a night a 23 list offline
it's a little long that is a long-term
question so a social media post later in
the week isn't fine but conver do you
want us to do work yeah
at the very least mark who I know has
done many Star Trek quit but this is an
offline later question bragging 23 feels
actually exactly but I mean Rath the
convoy let's reverse engineer what's the
last one
haha what the worst of the bunch yeah
maybe Star Trek on motion pictures like
Star Trek or the final frontier it's
like insurrection there's some moments
in insurrection on Star Trek the first
one is just like the glory shots the
enterprise the enterprise is you're
jamming in Kirk often there is this true
look at those cells all [ __ ] go see
this is why I love this bar this you
have this thought what's but even worry
we'll work on that offline offline
though my daughter will do a whole
[ __ ] thing but a much more fun I
think more relevant is the old-school
Marvel vs. DC Justice League versus
Avengers you are each team captains keV
team Justice League mark team Avengers
draft version six on six you can go one
alternate pick a chick you're gonna
draft the six on six team and then who
wins
would your person I think a lot of
sports I do
I get to pick six Justice League members
drafting go one you know go when all the
others on your team versus mark teams
it's not how they do it in the draft
that's how it goes in commerce do I get
the first draft don't get the first fast
pick Batman this young kid up-and-comer
Batman he might do our teams and go I
picked Batman you I mean the way this is
going to go is I'm just gonna pick that
Marvel analog for the character you
picked
that's why I went first iron man okay
I'm gonna pick Superman Thor
I'm gonna pick Zatanna Doctor Strange I
can do this all day for three mo all
right I'm gonna take magic wishy ring
Greenland Jon Stewart Green Lantern and
by Jon Stewart Green Lantern I mean the
former host of The Daily Show someone
with imagination should wield the ring
he seems very funny Professor X who
could call man yeah world's most
powerful mine until he goes [ __ ]
nuclear and then everyone dies in
Connecticut I get two more Wonder Woman
- I'll have a goddess on my team you
already got Thor though and she's a
pretty goddess as well
galactus what in the avengers [ __ ]
fair to take a world leader and hug and
put him on your team you got a guide man
alright [ __ ] fine death pick guess
what we always win I'm pretty sure that
was number seven for you no I think that
was my six was it six yeah
can I count your math that was six I
know no the math so good you got one
more I got one more gotta be death
somehow there ain't no character called
life that's your rugged default you're
like how do I beat death has anymore guy
swims good alright and we get you
getting an alt yeah one more and then
just debate who you guys think wins of
your two teams my alters mister makes
exploit Alec might mention my alt is
longshot Wow
after what just happened to him in
Deadpool to you still quick one oh no
that's dark long shot yeah really [ __ ]
it let's be lucky Wow I'll take lucky
over good
wow what a what a dumbass [ __ ] - you
know what Galactus on it it's fine it
was pretty good but it was like the
hottest sex or the weakest ending like
think you were [ __ ] this royal and
you like here it comes then you were
like
and you're like well I guess that's a
finish but not what I was thinking of
debate
I don't know deaf man I got that on my
side I don't see how he wins Death Comes
for everybody eventually I guess so [ __ ]
it we're all dead
excellent question you win tickets get
your tickets thank you see one on my
friend responsible dad well done what do
you got next sir take us there got two
more museum Pickler JC's been enjoying
all the compliments about his bar so
he's forgotten the man job but sitting
back there going I am pretty cool Lorna
he'll bring all this [ __ ] myself
well Bella the [ __ ] ball how are you
hi I'm doing great
my name's Russell Russell man hi
everyone what do you want to know rose
did it run so I was sitting in a Netflix
office last week and I was reading your
Kelly Marie Tran article in a Hollywood
Reporter I loved it I read it thank you
they only had like six comments when I
read it at the time the next morning I
looked back at it again there was 700
comments and it was your question
whatever difference between six and
seven hundred and I don't know math so
but I wanted to ask you mark how do you
deal with mental health wise like
Clemente how do you deal with those kind
of comments on when they [ __ ] on the
article you wrote and then for Kevin
what would Jay and Silent Bob do about
it I think we saw that movie take it
away I mean there is an old rule and
probably the only real rule that's not
rule 34 which i think is whatever you
can imagine
it's don't ever read the comments
nothing good comes from reading comments
good or bad you know like it it's either
some it'll inflate your ego or it will
crush your soul there's rarely a middle
road Twitter makes not reading the
comments harder because the comments
just suddenly flood across your face
whether you want them to or not but you
know like your your right a thing you
have an opinion you feel like you you've
justified that opinion you stand by what
you wrote so and people are as free as I
was to write it to disagree with it
you know I do not take any of it
personally because none of them know me
personally so they don't know what hurts
you know they're just casting wildly in
the dark hoping that at some point
they'll make me cry and I will never
tell them how often they do so it's it's
yeah like just kind of just keep
swimming then like that's kind of all
you can do as somebody who spends time
making stuff put it out there in the
world you hope everybody [ __ ] goes
along with it and always has nice [ __ ]
to say but unfortunately that's not the
how it works so you have to deal with a
lot of [ __ ] betrayal the last one I
went through which you know I've braced
for and and you know pre-lubricated for
was yoga hosers man like we went to
Sundance with the movie I was [ __ ]
thrilled those like oh my god we're
going back to Sundance for the movie I
made with my kid and you know for
whatever reason I guess because people
didn't like the movie they all decided
like up there to start [ __ ] on it
and you know I'd been through it before
I had the luxury of living through
something very similar when we made
Mallrats same thing all the critics
hated it and [ __ ] nobody saw it died at
the box office there was no internet so
there was not a bunch of people going
you suck but in the newspapers that you
know the folks were saying you suck so
if I've lived through it and I also know
that if you're patient and you know you
just go on with your [ __ ] life
sometimes it works out like people
didn't like Mallrats when I came out but
then 10 years later that was the movie
most people would talk to me about
so when yo goes out
yeah I understand like [ __ ] I'm
getting kicked in the balls now but I
also smart enough to know that like if I
wait ten years like people will be like
oh I like what you did back then if
you're patient and you're diligent you
can have everything you want in this
life you'll just never get it on the
schedule you're expecting and so you
can't go in there and go on like
especially if you're gonna make
something like [ __ ] yoga hosers you
can't expect the whole world to embrace
it when it happens sometimes they catch
up to it later that was the lesson that
Mallrats taught me like don't like Jim
Jackson was the producer of Mallrats I
remember he told me like after opening
weekend he's gone we're right we're just
early he goes you'll see and I never
knew what that meant until years later I
was like oh yeah that's right the movie
did work like we were right we were just
a little bit early and [ __ ] in the case
of writing an opinion piece like he's
really opening himself up for attacks in
the same way he would be for just
creating something and putting it out
there into the world but the opinion
piece makes him a little more vulnerable
at the end of the day because everyone's
got an opinion at least if it was his
thing you know people could say what
they want but he's like look I made what
I wanted to make that's the defense I
always get to stand behind it's like
look I get it you don't like it you're
making that very clear but I [ __ ]
love it
like this is exactly what I wanted it to
be so I guess I'm the fucked-up one here
but like that's what I wanted to do so
if you could stand by it at the end of
the day you know you just got to brave
the storm and it can get [ __ ] stormy
man it sucks when the Eye of Sauron
falls on you my [ __ ] yeah but it happens
sometimes have you spent time on the
internet and a high profile way from
time to time it happens it happened to
me once like just recently okay so my
was it this week or what are we Tuesday
last week Drake dropped the video the
for I'm upset and it was Degrassi themed
and so I was in a me and J we're in it
and I saw somebody wrote an Argo is a
lot of articles somebody wrote an
article where they were like this is the
most relevant Kevin Smith has been
since he got thrown off an airplane
years ago and at first I was like
[ __ ] and I was like they're
absolutely right like I mean I've been
running along doing my [ __ ] [ __ ] but
like I haven't popped up on this
person's radar since I was like where
they threw me off a [ __ ] plane so in
this person the author's perspective
yeah like fuggin is the last time I the
dude heard from me and next time is in a
[ __ ] at Drake video and I must be jizan
myself based on like being relevant
again and I was so he wasn't wrong
he absolutely wasn't wrong so sometimes
it helps to be able to I know like you
know he's saying never look at the
comments and [ __ ] but like sometimes it
helps absolutely you know you know you
got to know what you're dealing with out
there and and so for you know I've read
a lot of filmmakers be like I don't read
my reviews over the years I do I read
them all like you know I didn't make it
in a vacuum I made it to see what people
thought and so those people account as
folks who write a tweet they're like it
was awesome and keep it short or
somebody who writes a [ __ ] think
piece about what a [ __ ] idiot and I
am and how I've ruined my career over
the years or something everyone put in a
little time like I asked him to watch
something of mine or interact with
something of mine they did that thing I
got to sit there and listen to what they
say don't have to believe it you know
what I'm saying like at the end of the
day you can stick to your own guns be
like look that's your opinion I'm sorry
you didn't like it and believe me with
my career I say that a lot but I like it
like and if I like it that's why I made
it in the first place the only reason
we're having that discussion is because
I was in love with doing this thing and
you can't sell out on it just because
the rest of the world doesn't like it
you know I used to do that after Jersey
girl go and didn't like it I was like
yeah [ __ ] it let's shoot it you know and
so I don't do that anymore now I'm like
I get it you don't like it but oh my god
I thought I loved it it's my favorite
thing ever that's I mean it's it's I
remember very early on when I started
writing and it was right you know
screenplays and be early pilots and
stuff and I would send them to friends
to give me notes and and one of my
friends got him Zack Stemmons he was on
the show before I was dance next is you
roll at sort of run away a dinosaur for
the flash hero
first Thor II wrote x-men first class
and and and he told me something that
went a little bit like you don't want
people to think your stuff is okay you
want them to either hate it or love it
because the people who love it will be
the ones who want to make it they'll be
the ones who respond to it it's gonna be
somebody's favorite thing but with that
come somebody's least favorite thing so
you know there was a lot of [ __ ] [ __ ]
that came my way during the whole Star
Wars thing as it was during Black
Panther as it was during talking about
whitewashing as it was as it was as it
was but each one of you like I got it
like this makes sense to me I understand
what you were trying to say this mean
something to me I felt like like Willy
Wonka at the end of one with Chocolate
Factory was like so shines a good deed
in a cruel world like just one [ __ ]
person who got it isn't enough to make
the rest of it not really matter that
much because when you've you know when
you find one person for whom you vibrate
on the same frequency of that's why
you're doing it you know to be able to
find commonalities and people to be able
to find and speak to people who feel the
same way and change minds of people who
don't feel the same way that's and it's
fine like that if that's the ratio all
right
I spoke to one person that's good enough
it's like that episode of The Simpsons
remember when Kathleen Turner was the
lady who created Malibu Stacy and her
and Lisa got together and created Lisa
Lionheart and they were just about to
debut it and then they introduced Malibu
Stacy with a new hat and all the kids
businesses and then they saw one little
girl bought the Lisa Lionheart and lisas
like you know if we reach that one girl
it will all have been worth it and then
the other lady goes yes particularly if
that girl plays a million dollars for
that one girl and Lisa goes watch goes
oh nothing kudos to you Lisa
very very true excellent question give
it up for me one tickets well done man
Thank You Russell pleasure bang right
there kick them and we got one more how
are you good sir what's your name good
I'm Adam I just do it up for everybody
first of Adam there's one set of tickets
lap possibly with your name on oh I'm
gonna get them I like your confidence
Adam thank you thank you first of all
congratulations on the current success
mark and thank you it has not gotten
love here yet since I've been listening
the podcast but Kevin I [ __ ] love
Jersey girl oh thank you me too but I
[ __ ] breezed up for but I do love
them yeah I think it's great my question
for you guys is now with the benefit of
20/20 hindsight if they were able to
convince Christian Bale to play a Batman
in BVS and basically retcon it so he
came out of retirement because of
Superman do you think the whole DC you
would have been better number one I like
your movie a lot more have a good night
it feels like I mean was that they
weren't saying that Ben was Christian
Bale but they were saying like oh
there's been around for years you know
he's not that guy anymore I think I
would have preferred it and I'm not this
ain't [ __ ] on Affleck but as a guy
who loved the Nolan trilogy when they
announced like hey they're making Man of
Steel and Chris Nolan's a producer on it
I was like oh [ __ ] man so that means
like his Batman and his Superman will
coexist and then ultimately it wound up
in Zack Snyder's Superman Batman instead
I
I would have preferred the Christian
Bale version just as the continuity
freak of like yeah all these [ __ ]
indicated a little bit I think and also
it would have been like we're all what
does everyone [ __ ] about DC movies
doing like oh they're trying to be
Marvel like they can't catch up tomorrow
they had it right there they were like
we've been making these [ __ ] Batman
movies forever so now we're just gonna
connect him and guess what we got a
universe but instead they launched a
brand new universe inversely it's not
just like they're not they're trying to
be Marvel but it's like it's no Dark
Knight
but you had the Dark Knight there that's
and also you know like you you can go a
long way on sentimentality and affection
and we all love those [ __ ] Nolan
movies so the bar was already set high
and if you were like hey these are
continuation of those movies and he's
only gonna work a certain amount he's
not gonna be in every scene but it's
your Batman from the last 10 years that
would have been a [ __ ] very very
smart decision not only that but then it
becomes an emotional story it becomes
the what makes this guy give up
happiness like what this is the last
time we saw his in France
living his dream like granted we won't
discuss the fact that Batman [ __ ]
retired because Batman doesn't retire
but given that he retired what's enough
to pull his guy away from the dream that
he's always had of having the girl and
having the paradise and being able to
not be haunted and tortured by his
parents death what brings that guy to
put the suit back on and they still
could've did what they did right like
you still do Man of Steel we're [ __ ]
Superman fights odd and you still have
that be the inciting incident that makes
eval go like I've got to stop this mania
yeah nothing else has to change
yes Casper's no like II guess it's not
like [ __ ] and I don't get this sense
that you're [ __ ] on Affleck and
neither am i it's great it's just about
like what would have been better
fanservice for the you know those movies
and not just fanservice
would have made financial sense those
movies made a buck or two so like if you
have a few screwed on the phone and say
you know I'm sorry Bruce but 8,000
people died in Bruce Tower what happened
how do you say that we set everybody up
to save roost our dad he's like [ __ ] all
everything Wayne Bruce its Bruce now
it's our this is the Bruce cave my Bruce
lunch I like but that I like I like your
version of Batman V Superman but at that
point it's Batman 4 and Superman - yeah
you know I mean and like it validates
everything that's going on yeah I'm sure
Christian Bale had a say in all this and
chose not to but still I feel like it
would have made it that's what I was
gonna say him they went after him and
they offered him they backed up the
money truck and they were look please
[ __ ] do it again we'll give you over
20 million from what I understood I
wasn't in the room but he was like now
I'm done with these mate I'm done for
told somebody to get out of his eyeline
and [ __ ] off
so I he they tried to get him and it
didn't pan out but I don't think it was
stupid to get Ben I thought he'd cut a
dashing Batman figure in the costume and
I think it was smart he was coming off a
[ __ ] Argo as well but Christian Bale
would have made all the difference right
just because you're right it would have
been Batman for essentially could have
kept it going man and that would have
like backdoored you into a universe at
the same time that Marvel started
there's Dark Knight came out the same
summer as as Iron Man is that dark yeah
a dark night date I think so so then by
the time you get to the Dark Knight
Rises the next that's Avengers 2 yeah so
you're and you're on your way to a back
to our universe I guess I don't and then
you call it Man of Steel the Dark Knight
Returns
ooh man is still to the Dark Knight
Returns don't you think you do the -
just like a dark night it's just
subtitling it yeah he was like a little
stamp like wreckit-ralph to is on that
[ __ ] poster
but that was the original plan like
originally was X nighter was gonna do
Man of Steel too and they were like
we're gonna let you play with Batman
he's like we're bringing Batman into it
and then it just became that may be
super Batman V Superman wow man that's a
good [ __ ] idea wait was that a
question you're just telling us what
would be better yeah wouldn't that be
awesome
Matis it's so good it doesn't even have
to be a question man well in that case
no I don't have a question well as long
as you just end up wouldn't miss be
awesome well I guess the question was
was like if let's say BBS was the exact
same script and everything was the same
except for the first scene is oh [ __ ]
shit's going down you know Fox like no
seriously you got to come back to town
shit's real and everything else is the
same
would BBS have been perceived better and
I think yes but sounds like you guys
think so too absolutely better yes be
better you gotta fix them yeah it's like
maybe and when Belle shows up like even
gonna fix this [ __ ] script because I
could be a cobbler in the middle of
Dublin right now if I wanted to I'm
gaining all this [ __ ] weight for
American hustle this has got to be
awesome gonna lose it again yeah but he
wasn't the cobbler that was Daniel
day-lewis or all the same oh my god
you're profiling all actors like they
all want to make British shoes British
actors are this that is I know is I
don't know about the question but it was
an excellent point one that deserves
tickets you were absolutely right you
win yes it's a bummer man that's like
you know [ __ ] you know like I got a
drive home thinking about that God like
God that would have worked like [ __ ]
crazy and we wouldn't be having all
these conversations about the DC
Universe and stuff in in terms of
pejorative conversations right I saw
some people online were a little upset
that I asked what they felt was a very
leading question about the DC movies to
Markus and McFeely last week they're
like come on man it's unfair and [ __ ]
but I thought they gave wonderful
answers I didn't think they [ __ ] on the
other movies whatsoever
but it is also like I'm a fan of both
and they both of those series of movies
have gotten my money time and time again
but you know I'm just kind of curious
what those cats were did I thought they
give a really good [ __ ] answer they
did not one that would piss off anybody
and what not one that would piss off
anybody I don't especially who might
eventually give them work what do we do
what should we do for guests in the in
the future cuz that really kind of
worked out it's worked out when we've
done guests like it has yeah I mean who
do you guys want us to get it yeah who's
everybody wanted well here let's well
let's make them gettable please like
we're not gonna get Christian BAFF to
the [ __ ] ten minutes we just did Tom
Cruise is never showing up here Seth
Rogen or Joe Rogan with Rogen Joe Rogan
I think this would scare Joe Rogan I
don't know the cantina bar is Joe's vibe
to be sure more screenwriters I agree I
thought those guys were really [ __ ]
interesting and had great answers well
we didn't we've been talking a bit with
Gary Whitta about coming down with San
Francisco and he was like yeah that's a
good call he'll be coming up who else
Geoff Johns what a great [ __ ] call
man let's get him here have him talk
line so who make them gettable Kevin
Feige is the white whale man like
hugging if I can if I can nail him Fox
we can get him here I don't know if
we'll get him here in this place but
that seems more like a fat cave kind of
thing you have him come over and be at
the house and stuff but yeah oh [ __ ] I
want to dive deep with him and
everyone's just like oh you want to ask
for a job not at all man those I just
want to [ __ ] die
I just want to tell about my good friend
mark garden but me I just want to pan
out be like what are you gonna do next
man what's the future look like in [ __ ]
you know spoilers and stuff so yeah
hopefully
who else wait hold on say again
Mike Mike Tyson Neil deGrasse Tyson
alright that makes more sense man I was
like so did you like boxing could you
get up mr. t Neil deGrasse Tyson that's
a good pole yeah he'd be comfy here and
stuff
Dan Harmon excellent [ __ ] oh yeah Dan
Harmon be very comfortable here right
[ __ ] doesn't that be a good idea never
Li can and I did him for SModcast yeah
part two might be nice to do it here and
stuff those are all thought who else
Kathleen Kennedy she'll never give us
the time of day III so Kathleen Kennedy
my kid went to school with her daughter
and so I saw her a few times
over the years one time she came by the
house to pick up her kid lovely woman we
chitchat in the chit but I wanted to ask
her like hey I do a podcast called fat
man on Batman and and my wife was like
don't you [ __ ] open your mouth to her
Kevin I was like how can I know she is
the most the single most successful
producer on the [ __ ] planet and she's
like here at the house like I gotta ask
her if she'll be in the pod and my wife
silenced me I couldn't do it instead
when when I went to the rogue one
premiere yes where we we hung out and I
was talking to Harley after the premiere
like that dis after-party at the Avalon
hotel I think and I ran into Harley and
as I go away what you think that you
were off being Kevin Smith and I'm the
guy it's [ __ ] Harley and she was there
with a friend of hers from school I said
hey how are you good mean ER doctors ago
so what'd you think of the movie well I
liked it I dug it this is right up my
alley zinc what about you sign habit now
did you get in here just like my mom
produced it
and then he looked at me like you [ __ ]
wreck to kick you to [ __ ] I say
anything good come out of his mouth like
I hated it this is [ __ ] [ __ ]
what a collective waste of time this was
for everybody who produced this message
second act you that all kinds have
[ __ ] problems here via music it is it
yeah it's I remember that okay Kathleen
Kennedy know who else george RR martin
yeah he could be a get while he's in
town
i met him at the neuchâtel film festival
years ago and he was so [ __ ] nice and
fun and [ __ ] like that and he and i
wasn't even a big game of thrones person
at that point then I saw the show
afterwards cuz I sat down chit-chatted
with him but he did tell me a funny
story he was like I said was the
difference between being a [ __ ]
author before the show and after the
show he goes you sign a lot more books
after the show I said really goes yeah
like [ __ ] before the show I go to a
book signing and you know twenty people
be there and I'd sign a book and I
talked to him and stuff and then we'd
all go home sometimes we'd all go out to
eat together he's gone but now book
signing is like a thousand people show
up and suppose they get out of here and
he told me story about being in some
foreign country and he was signing a
thousand books and looking a line just
kept going people come up with their
copies of his books and he'd be writing
like [ __ ] and he's like I alternated
between best wishes george RR martin and
winter's coming george RR martin and
he's like at one point they came over
and made the people who organized the
signing they're like george you should
probably take a break and he was like
why he was like because you've been
signing books wishes are coming
ladies and gentlemen have you had a good
time this evening we cannot thank you
enough for being here Malthus scum and
villainy cantina right here in Hollywood
but there is no fat man I'm Batman
without the smart one give it up to the
guy to my left mr. Marc Bernardo and
that is fat man on Batman for this week
I'm Kevin Smith I am muttering on tune
in next time same fat time same fat
channel SModcast calm or youtube.com
slash Kevin Smith
[Applause]
[Music]
you